uh prime minister Trudeau are you
willing to stay publicly to Canadians
that Canada is now at a pro in a proxy
war with Russia if you can give us a yes
or no answer and a brief
um reasoning why or why not
Russia's illegal invasion of Ukraine
upended 80 years
of Peace stability and security around
the world one of the most prosperous
eras the world has ever known we have
all benefited benefited from that
immeasurably everywhere around the world
Russia's decision
to end
that peace to violate
the U.N
Charter
to overturn international law to
arbitrarily choose to redraw lines on a
map
is of course of deep concern to Canada
in regards to our friends in Ukraine
but should be of real concern to
everyone around the world
everywhere around the world there are
authoritarian dictators looking at
Vladimir Putin
curious to see if he will succeed
because everywhere around the world
there are neighbors with larger armies
than the country beside them saying Oh
wouldn't it be nice to redraw the map
wouldn't it be nice to be able to invade
and benefit from that and get a few more
resources or or bring in uh people who
speak the same language
this choice that Canada has to stand
unequivocally with Ukraine is yes of
course about the Deep friendship and the
the personal and family and and
demographic ties that we've had with
Ukraine for over a century
but it is also about the right thing to
do
right now Ukraine is yes fighting for
its territorial Integrity its right to
determine its own future and that is
very important and we'll be there for
that
but it's also fighting for the values
and the principles
that underpin all of our democracies all
of the stability and freedom that we've
been able to build in international law
over the past years that's why Canada
stands unequivocally with Ukraine that's
why we will continue to do everything
necessary to ensure that Ukraine
prevails